and I'm rolling so as you guys know we
like and cutting so as you guys know we
like to talk about how to get cool shots
and there's a lot of ways to do that you
can get a crane you can get a jib arm
you can get a dolly you can even use
warp stabiliser to improve your
hand-held footage in my opinion there's
a definitive way to get cool shots and
that's using a drone or a UAV or
whatever name you decide to call this
basically this is a quadcopter it's
essentially a fancy RC helicopter they
make a lot of toy versions of these but
what makes this one different is that
it's actually designed to have a higher
payload allowing us to essentially mount
a GoPro camera and get cool aerial shots
wherever we want this one in particular
is actually called the DJI phantom and
we featured it in other videos
previously and we got this from drone
fly comm which basically sells these and
all these cool accessories you can get
from we've been experimenting with it
and I'm gonna tell you guys how it works
a little windy out today it always makes
me nervous even though I know it really
shouldn't be a problem booting it up and
right now these drones actually linked
up with GPS satellites to determine its
position this allows it to actually like
remember where it is in
three-dimensional space the light is
blinking green that means it's linked up
with the satellites so I'm gonna take
this thing for a spin
and I'm rolling on there
using the combination of GPS and
everything in the sensors inside is able
to pretty much stay on autopilot like
this my hands aren't even on the
controls much compensate for any any
wind being thrown at it which is pretty
nice
so just like you need a shock mount for
your microphone when using it it's
actually good to have a shock mount or
something similar for your camera while
attaching it to a throne like this the
reason is because of the propellers is
that when they're all spinning basically
it causes micro vibrations within the
camera you can get an actual shock mount
for your GoPro or you can just quickly
put one together using some foam DJI is
now making actually a gimbal head which
is basically a self stabilizing camera
rig which will automatically correct for
most motion that the drone will give you
but basically that's one big thing to
keep in mind especially when using
cameras with rolling shutters such as a
GoPro you'll start seeing your photo to
look all wobbly or really kind of
painted about to take out so make sure
you keep that in mind we're actually
gonna be using a even more crazy Regulus
on an upcoming shoot one that actually
allows us to control the camera
separately from the body of the drone
you'll see more about that in our next
behind the scenes so I hope you guys
learned something and if you have any
questions it's up on Twitter or Facebook
or email or whatever suits you best
you